[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES LAU: Thank you.
Thanks for being
here this morning.
My name is James, and I'm part
of the Kotlin team at Google.
Today, I have the pleasure
of introducing a very
special guest from
JetBrains, who really
requires no introduction.
Now, all of you know
that Kotlin is now
one of the most
loved programming
languages in the world.
And at Google I/O,
it's very rare for us
to have external speakers.
But this person
was here last year,
and we invited him back because
we couldn't think of anybody
else better to teach
Kotlin, other than one
of the people who invented it.
So please help me welcome
the lead language designer
for Kotlin, Andrey Breslav.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREY BRESLAV:
Thank you, James.
Thanks for a great introduction.
Hello, everybody.
I'm very glad to see you here.
Today, I'm going to talk
about what can it be--
Kotlin-- I guess.
And I really am going
to do a live demo,
so please bring my demo on.
So the reason why I have this
horrible code in the slides
is that we are all learning,
and our old habits sometimes
get in the way.
So I'll be presenting today on
the topic of how you get out
of your Java habits and
get to your Kotlin habits.
So we all come from different
backgrounds, of course.
And many of us started with
the Java programming language
and built up our knowledge
of programming through this.
So we remember many things.
And the thing is Kotlin has
been inspired by many languages,
including the Java
programming language.
So you can reproduce many of
the Java constructs in Kotlin.
And it will work.
You can get your
job done this way,
but it can be, in many
cases, improved dramatically.
So this particular example
is about declaring classes.
And you can see here that I
have a Kotlin class on the left
and the Java class on the right.
And they look very similar.
But this is definitely not
how we write Kotlin code.
So what do you are
actually supposed to do
is remove all the
unnecessary stuff.
What I have to say here is
two properties, one class.
That's it, right?
So I can try to
transform it by hand,
but I actually want to
show off a nice tool.
And simply copy and paste
the code from the Java side
to the Kotlin side, so it
will use the Java to Kotlin
converter built into the
IDE, and do it for me.
So boom, there it is.
A single line that's
actually all you
needed to declare one
class, two properties.
That's it.
All I have here is a class
with a primary constructor.
So it has two parameters and
both of them are properties.
And that's all
you wanted to say.
So this is one of
the things that
demonstrates how cheap
declaring classes is in Kotlin.
And there's a
consequence to this.
So look at this code.
Here, it's obviously not how
you're supposed to write code
in any language, actually.
I wanted to parse a full
name into a first name
and a last name.
And so that's what
I'm doing here.
But how do I pack the result
to put it out of the function?
I don't have a way of returning
two things from a function.
I have to put into one object.
And I'm abusing a list here,
then awkwardly taking out one
and the other to make a
first name and a last name.
Don't do this in any language.
But there is kind of
a psychological reason
to doing this, at least
in our old habits,
because declaring classes
is expensive, right?
You have to create a new
file, put a lot of code in it.
It's kind of awkward.
But in Kotlin, you
don't have to do this.
All you need to say,
my class, full name,
with first and last
names as properties.
And then, all I need to do
here is just return that.
So my full name.
Here it goes.
And now instead of indices, I
can say first and last right
here.
So that's the idea.
Classes being
cheap is not always
saving you time at
the declaration site,
it's saving you mental effort.
You can represent your
multiple return as a class
and it doesn't
cost you anything.
So if I run this, you'll
see that my equals
doesn't work, obviously, because
that's a single-line class.
And so now I'll go to
declare equals there,
and then a hash code there,
and so on and so forth.
It's so verbose.
But I really don't need
to do this in Kotlin,
because you probably
know that there is
something called data classes.
Who knows data classes?
Many people, good.
So you know that I simply
put this single keyword there
and the compiler generates many
things for me-- it's equal,
it's hash code,
it's to a string,
and many other
convenient methods.
So that's it.
Change your mind about
how expensive a class is.
You can use it easily in
all your abstractions.
So more or less done
with the warm up.
Let's look at something else--
properties.
So we talked about classes.
We'll go through properties,
and then go over to functions.
So here is a property done
the way you shouldn't do it
in Kotlin, again.
So the problems that
I showed you before
were kind of one-liners where
both the getter and setter is
trivial.
If you want a custom
setter, you definitely
don't define functions for that.
You have your custom setter
syntax, as you probably know.
If you know data
classes, you know that.
So inside a custom setter,
you have field to--
not filed, but field--
to write to your backend
storage, but that's it.
You don't need to introduce
extra names in anything else.
So that's
straightforward, right?
But then look at this code.
So here is already
some sensible logic.
I have two properties, one
of them private and nullable
and mutable.
And on my first access, I'm
checking if that's null,
and then I compute a
value and write into it.
And then I output,
return it from my getter.
So what is it?
It's a lazy property, right?
I personally wrote
dozens and thousands
of those in Java and
many other languages,
so I got kind of bored by that.
And that's why Kotlin has an
abstraction mechanism called
delegation for properties.
So delegated properties
let you get rid
of all the repetition
of this lazy logic.
All we care about is
this expression here.
So let's just do it.
Implement my property by
just lazy of all this.
This is it.
So what I'm having
now, I'm saying
my property is not simply
initialized by something.
It's delegated to
this lazy thing here.
And upon first access, this
lambda will be executed.
And then, the rest will
be stored by the library.
So lazy is not a
language construct,
it's just a library function.
You can define your own.
And the library provides
you with many other things.
So the takeaway
here is that if you
have a common kind of property,
like observable for example,
when you need to be notified
that something was modified,
use a library or write your own.
So here, delegates.observable
does the job
from the standard library.
But if you like, you don't
have to write code like this.
When you have one property,
and then the other property,
and the other doing the same and
same thing over and over again,
all you need to do
is this, actually.
Declare a single class
that encapsulates
the logic of your property,
like your generic getter
and generic setter.
And that's it.
You can now simply refer to
this class in many properties
and get your business
logic database access,
all kinds of validation.
Anything you like can be
abstracted as a library
and then reused
across your project.
Does it make sense?
Who uses this already?
I don't know.
So many people.
You actually should.
I'm sure you can
benefit from this.
So this is more or less
it about properties.
And now, let's get to functions.
Functions are very
important, right?
So again, this is
very horrible code.
Don't write code like
this in Kotlin, please.
This is very much
inspired by our habits
in the Java programming
language, when I have
to put everything into a class.
So StringUtil-- does your
project has its own StringUtil
class?
Oh, if it doesn't, it's just
a very new project, right?
So any of my projects have them.
But the thing is, in Kotlin,
it's a little different.
You don't have to use a class.
Well, first of all, Kotlin
classes don't have statics.
So to use these functions
from this class,
you have to say a
StringUtil, parentheses,
which makes a new object.
I don't want a new
object every time.
I want it like this, so I turn
this class into an object.
It's a little bit of an
improvement in my insanity,
right?
So I was creating
an object every time
I wanted to call a function.
That's crazy.
But really, in Kotlin, I don't
need any enclosing container
at all because I have
top-level functions.
So this may seem obvious like
functions, what are they?
They're just
declarations, right?
But some languages have them
only in classes and many people
learn this and rely on this.
So this is a lot
more of a Kotlin way,
but it's still
not great in terms
of what you can achieve with
Kotlin, because here, you
have two overloads.
So getFirstWord is
supposed to parse a string,
find a first space, and take
the first word, and return it.
But what if the separator
is not a space, but a comma
or something?
So here is a more
full-featured version.
And then, this is how
you'll call it actually
in most contexts.
So what I wanted to express
here is just a default value.
In Java, we are used to
using overloads for this,
and also some people
use nullable parameters
like pass and null here, and
I'll give you a default value.
Don't do this in Kotlin.
You don't need to.
So all you need to do actually,
is simply specify your default.
My default is space, here.
That's it.
So there was no need
to emulate defaults.
They are both into the language.
And same for when you
have many, many default
parameters with
different values,
like multiple Booleans,
so on, so forth.
You can just use named parameter
syntax to express which of them
you actually need.
And all of the rest
will be used by default.
So this makes functions
fewer in the first place,
and then a lot more expressive.
OK.
Good with functions, right?
Well, actually, this
function is kind of midway
between the Kotlin
style and the Java style
because it's actually
working on strings.
Very much a good idea to put
this into a string class.
Oh, wait, it's not.
Because the string class
is not controlled by you,
you can't put everything
into the string class.
And you really want to keep
the string API minimal.
So what I would
really like to do
is something like this,
where I can say my string,
getFirstWord, and that's it.
So it looks like a method.
It's called an extension
function, actually.
It's not sitting
in a string class.
I didn't go into the JDK and
alter the class I can control.
But still, it works like this.
So this is the
mechanism you can use.
I'll do it manually to
illustrate how it works here.
So I have a receiver
of type string.
Now, I don't need this
parameter anymore.
And I can say this dot
here, and use my this here
or omit all of this
on the left-hand side.
So now, I'll be able
to use it this way.
Make sense?
I can do the same
with a property.
Actually, it would be very
nice to do it this way--
just so I have first
word as a property name.
And you can have an
extension property.
Of course, there will
be no customization
for the separator, but
otherwise you're good to go.
Yep, I'll just need
to put a space here.
And that's it.
So extension functions,
extension properties--
it's actually a
very important idea.
It's not only just convenience.
It allows you to keep your
classes really minimal.
So look at the string
class in Kotlin.
It's only five methods.
If you compare that to Java,
it will be screens and screens
of declarations.
So you can keep
your API minimal.
And all the utility
functions can be extensions,
can sit in different libraries,
can be modularized like this.
And that's a very important
tool for designing APIs.
Do you have questions?
OK.
I couldn't take them anyway.
OK, now, let's have
a look at this.
Here, I'm doing
something very typical.
I'm traversing a hierarchy.
So I have containers
and leaf elements.
Containers can be
nested in one another.
Leaf elements sit there.
All leaf elements
hold text and I
want to extract all the
text from this hierarchy.
Pretty straightforward.
So my classes are
three lines of code--
not much.
There's an element.
There's a container with
the list of children.
There is text.
Now, I'm traversing this.
So I'm using
extension functions.
I'm using top-level functions,
everything as I told you.
So it's all right, but
I don't like this code.
Why don't I like it?
Here, to traverse a
hierarchy, I need recursion.
So I need to pass the string
builder down the stack
and add to it as I'm
going down the tree.
But then, I end up with
top-level function that's
only needed by this one here.
So this one is not
really needed anywhere
but inside this function.
So what I'd really like to
do is just put it inside--
just go here and make
it a local function.
So again, it's just expressing
that nobody else needs this.
You don't need private
helpers anymore--
a look for local helpers.
And this can be
improved a little bit.
You can actually
make use of closure.
So I can create my
string builder right here
and get rid of all this.
So I don't need to return
or take parameters here.
All I need here is use
whatever is declared above.
And then I just do
extractText of e right here
and return string
builder toString.
ExtractText-- oh, sorry-- it's
an extension function, right?
No, sorry.
Yeah, so here is how it goes.
You can turn something into
a local function and leverage
closure.
So this variable is declared
outside my function.
It's not accessible to
anyone outside the outer.
And I'm using it
here and that's it.
Now, local functions, extension
functions, top-level functions,
default parameters-- use these.
They will make your code nicer.
Now, let's look at
what's still there.
Do you see grey code?
Grey code is useless.
The IDE and the compiler show
you that something is not
needed there, and
it actually isn't.
This class is redundant because
we have this is check here.
So you simply can remove this.
And I don't know if you see--
oh, yeah, you do--
but the text variable
has gone green.
Why is it green?
It's because the compiler can
figure out the casts for you.
It's actually much safer.
It's not only convenient.
I'm really annoyed at my
casts all over the place.
So I know it's text.
Why don't you know?
Well, now it knows.
And actually, you don't
need this variable either
because it's the only usage.
And it's same thing here.
And then, my container
can be inline as well.
So here it is.
I can use smart casts.
It makes your code
safer, more concise.
And actually, it makes
all the casts that still
are in your program meaningful.
So when you see an as
operator in Kotlin now,
you know it means something.
It's not just a useless
compliment to the
is check above.
Also this thing here is kind of
stupid because what I'm doing,
I'm just applying the same
function to everything.
And it's a single function.
So what I want to do
is something like this.
That's a little
bit nicer looking.
And then, let's look
at what we have.
We are traversing a hierarchy.
I have my leaves.
I have my containers.
And that's what I want
to express, right?
I'm checking different cases.
So to do that, it's a lot
nicer to use a when statement.
When can switch in
types right here.
But there is an
annoying thing about it.
And it's again, coming
from my old habits.
I'm declaring a close hierarchy.
I have only containers
and text, right?
I don't have anything else.
But now, I have this pretty
annoying else case right here.
Why?
Because the compiler
has no idea.
I don't have anything
but containers and text.
It's just an abstract class
and I have some cases there.
But you can actually express
this in Kotlin with sealed.
I can have a sealed
class, which means
all the subclasses are known.
You can declare them
outside this file.
And this way, the
IDE and the compiler
know that this else is useless.
So we went from almost
two screens of code
to less than one, simply
applying the idioms of Kotlin
to this code.
Do you have questions?
I'm sorry.
All right.
So now, let's just
continue with this exercise
and look at some more examples
of expressions that are written
like with old habits in mind.
And we'll try to transform
them into something better.
So the first thing that
really stands out here is var.
I can't say never use var.
Vars are useful.
Mutable variables can be
used for many nice things.
But it's kind of discouraged.
If you need a var, you
need a very good reason.
Here is not good reason
using a val, definitely.
Then here, let's
look at these three.
It's repetition.
Repetition is ugly.
Repetition is
error-prone, especially
if this was not a single
name, but many things chained.
So I would like to get
rid of this repetition.
What I can do is say, with ex.
Does anyone remember Pascal?
Pascal, anyone?
Oh, good.
Good.
I started in Pascal, almost.
So it had this weird thing,
which was a building construct.
In Kotlin, it's a function.
We can use it.
And here, we can get
rid of all the ex things
here, just like this.
And now it looks even
more stupid, right?
I'm just assigning to
the same variables.
Don't do that.
OK, so now I have a print line
with string plus something,
string plus something,
string plus something.
It's awkward.
Most languages now have
string interpolation.
Kotlin has that as well.
So what you actually
need here is this.
OK, done with this one.
Import things into
your scope with with.
Use string
interpolation, it's nice.
Now here, I'm creating
a map the old way.
I can kind of make it a
little nicer like this
by using my operators,
but it's really much nicer
if I just use a
builder function.
So what I can do here is replace
all my map things with pairs.
Oh, not pairs, but pair, sorry.
Typing when talking
is difficult.
Yeah, so a map can be
constructed of pairs, right?
And map was only a set of
pairs from key to value.
But actually, pairs are
kind of redundant in this,
so we're usually using
the to function here.
It's not a built-in operator,
just a library function
here, so this is how
you create a map.
And when you want
to traverse the map,
you can say here, key
and value, and just
have your variables
like this, which makes
for loops a lot more concise.
This example of code,
with my if statement,
is something I really hated
about my code in Java.
Because these assignments here,
they all fall apart so easily,
so I really like to do
things like this in Kotlin.
So if, and many other things,
are actually expressions.
This is something
pretty unfamiliar
for the C language family.
We are used to dividing
our code into statements
and expressions, right?
Statements are things
that have effects.
Expressions are things
that have values.
So you assign expressions to
variables and write statements
to assign things to things.
So Kotlin is halfway between
this procedural tradition
and functional tradition.
So we have a lot more
expressions than you're
used to in other languages.
So you can do this here.
And of course, you
don't have to use a var.
You don't have to
make a different line.
And you can assign
it right away.
So if expression, make it nicer.
By the way, the result
of the expression
is the last thing in the block.
So the same for when.
When is not simply
switch case on steroids,
it's largely and
importantly, an expression.
So you can also do
it like this, right?
So not many returns
here, but one return here
will be a lot nicer.
Also you don't have to repeat
yourself, of course, this much.
And you can say even this.
By the way, if you want to check
if something is odd and even,
don't do it like me.
It's only for demo purposes.
Don't try this at home.
It will hurt.
Yeah, so this one can be
further simplified like this.
So again, you're trying
to remove the noise.
When you see code
like this, just
try to get rid of the noise.
Noise is harmful for your brain.
Last thing, just a
quick demo of what
do you do with nullability.
So these question marks-- who's
familiar with nullable types
in Kotlin?
How many people?
I'll go really, really quick.
So you can nullable types.
And compiler makes you
do things like this.
So it's in there now.
The string is nullable.
You can dereference it.
You can either do this,
which says just safely
dereference me--
which by the way,
you can do here
as well so you don't have
to write an if around it.
And you can actually
simplify it like this.
Another nice thing
is that you can
use an elvis operator like
this, so to simplify your longer
if statements into something.
And this is kind of curious
because this is definitely
in an expression
position, right?
So how elvis works?
Elvis takes an expression to
the left-hand side of a string,
asks are you a
null really nicely.
And then if it's a null, it
evaluates the right-hand side.
But the right-hand side has
to be an expression, right?
Basically, it's supposed
to be a default.
So if you are now on
the left-hand side,
use a default on
the right-hand side.
But your default can
be just a return,
which means that you don't
compute any value there.
You just jump out
of the function.
And that's a quite interesting
thing from the type system
standpoint, but I'm not
giving a lecture here.
I'm doing a demo.
OK, we're good with expressions.
Let's look at some
functional style.
So people very often
refer to Kotlin
as a functional language.
I don't think it is, actually.
I think Kotlin is a
multi-paradigm language that
supports functional style.
You don't have to write
functional in Kotlin,
but it's oftentimes
very nice to do it.
So let's have a look at this.
So in my Java old
days in mind, I
wrote this code, which just
goes over a list of numbers
and picks those that
are divisible by 16,
and then converts them to hex.
So what it actually does
is filter map, right?
Map is this one, and
filter is this one.
So what I can do, even with the
help of my IDE, I can do this.
So newer versions of all
programming languages
have something like this.
It can definitely leverage this.
So this filter is a function.
This lambda is a function value.
You don't have, by the way,
to declare it as a variable.
You can just get rid of it.
So that's a lambda parameter.
Kotlin has some nice
semi-functional things,
like you can say anywhere in
your code, you can say also.
You have this value, also do
this for me please-- like print
this list for me.
And then proceed with
what you were doing.
Like never mind this, it's
just debug output or some side
effect I want to insert here.
Side effects are not very
functional, on the one hand.
On the other hand, this is
very handy for debugging.
You don't have to break
your chain apart, and so on,
so forth.
Use also, use let, use
run, and so on, so forth.
There is one very deep thing
about functional abstractions
in non-functional languages.
When I do something like this,
I have my repeat function
right here, right?
So what it does,
it takes a number
of times I want to
repeat something,
and this something
is a function.
By the way, you don't have
to invent your own function
interface every time, just
use the function types here.
It's a function that takes
an int or it takes a unit.
Unit is something
you don't care about.
Then, it simply
repeats it, right?
So when I say repeat, I'm always
very much conscious about what
it's going to cost me.
So it's a function.
It takes a lambda
as a parameter.
So it's actually just
another parameter.
The Kotlin custom is to write
it outside the parentheses
because it looks more like a
language construct like this.
But then, OK, I'm running this.
I have to create a
lambda object, right?
I have to create a lambda
object every time I
do anything like this.
So there is a cost
to this abstraction.
It's nice code.
I can reuse things.
I can raise the level of
abstraction in my code.
But there is a toll on that.
Actually in Kotlin, you
can very often get rid
of the toll of green lambdas--
lambda objects-- for you, by
just using inline functions.
When I say inline, my
code doesn't change.
So here, nothing happened at
the call site that I can see.
But if I say show
Kotlin bytecode,
and just decompile
this into to Java--
just to scare you a little bit.
It was much of an
easy talk so far.
So if I do this--
here it goes-- it's
a simple for loop.
Where did my lambda go?
Well, the compiler
simply optimized it away.
You don't need a lambda.
So if you simply have your loop
here and you inline everything,
you end up with a loop.
That's it.
So the big difference
in the mindset
when you go from the
Java programming language
to the Kotlin
programming language
is that you still use lambdas,
but some of your lambdas
are really free.
And by the way, these
all are free too.
So many, many lambdas
in the standard library
are free abstractions.
You don't have to
pay for calling them.
It's just code
generated for you.
So functional in Kotlin is not
only convenient, but also quite
cheap.
Speaking of cheap, by the way,
let's look at this example.
So here, I'm trying to do
a parallel computation.
Well, it's a stupid sample.
Nobody does parallel
computation in bare threads,
so on, so forth, but I
want to illustrate a point.
So what I'm doing
here is, again,
with my old habits in mind,
I'm creating 100,000 threads--
100,000 threads, each of
which does some work--
actually, sleeps for one second
and just prints a number.
And then, I have to
join all these threads
to my main thread.
So if I run this--
oh, oh, oh, that
was an exception.
What was that?
The Java lang out
of memory error.
Basically, what it's
telling me, hey, you
can not create 100,000 threads.
Are you crazy there?
It's 100,000 stacks.
It doesn't fit into memory.
Just get reasonable.
And that's fair.
OS threads are not cheap.
You have to allocate
resources for threads.
So you don't do such
silly things with threads,
but I have this example
down through coroutines.
Who knows about
coroutines in Kotlin?
Oh, good.
Who uses them in production?
OK, soon enough you all will
be using them, I'm sure.
So have a look here.
It's very much the same code.
So I'll just put it
side by side here.
Very much the same code,
but instead of threads here,
I'm creating async tasks
which are using coroutines
underneath.
So I'm still waiting for
one second and printing.
And if I run this, there
is no out of memory.
It's printing all the
numbers and I'm good.
So again, Kotlin
introduced coroutines
as a means of making
your asynchronous
computations nicer.
And that works, but
what's the cost of that?
So the cost of that
is at least cheaper
than having a thread
per each computation.
Of course, nobody
does that exactly,
but still coroutines
are very cheap.
You can spin off like
100,000 coroutines, a million
coroutines, and it doesn't
cost you nearly as much
as anything like
that old threads.
Let me illustrate something
coroutines are really
good for right here.
So here is a legacy
interface or--
I don't know-- or a [INAUDIBLE]
interface-- whatever.
So what we very often have to
do to make things asynchronous
or make things like
reverse our dependencies,
so on, so forth, is callbacks.
So just ask me to do something.
I'll do it for you.
And I'll let you
know when I'm done.
So here, I have my mock service,
a request, and a callback
function that's passed to it.
So when the work in
the comments are done,
I'm calling the callback and
just passing my answer there.
So that's all right.
It's working for
everyone, right?
But this is what the
code looks like when
I want to exchange messages
between two services.
So I just want to basically
send two messages in sequence.
And here is what I have to do.
First, request.
Then a callback.
This is the result
of the request.
I print it.
Then next request
inside that callback.
And then print inside.
So you see the staircase
right here, right?
One step-- oh, sorry.
One step, two
steps, three steps.
And you can actually
get quite deep
down this staircase,
which is not nice.
So what I would
really love to do
is something a little
more straightforward,
but so this is
kind of tolerable.
But what if-- just
imagine-- what if you
needed to do like n calls?
Just a number-- like
make a list of calls.
So this is the code I came up
with, which isn't nice at all.
So I definitely need
recursion there,
because I have to nest a
callback inside a callback
inside a callback, right?
So I need recursion.
This is the shortest code
I could come up with.
It copies arrays.
Don't do that.
It's wasteful in
terms of memory,
wasteful in terms of time.
It's quadratic.
But basically, you
have to come up
with something like
this-- like nest callbacks
into callbacks into callbacks.
And so you can't just say, OK,
repeat this five times, right?
So what I really
want to be able to do
is something like this, where I
just say, OK, send one request,
wait for results, send
the other request.
And then if I want
to repeat something,
just repeat it with a for loop.
So this code here is actually
using the same callbacks.
Only the coroutine abstractions
are distributing this away
from me.
So actually, you can take any
callback-based API you have
now, and turn it into this--
like make it straightforward--
with just a few lines of code.
I'll show you.
So this is calling
the same services,
because I have this
function right here.
So what I'm doing, I'm
just turning the request
into a suspension function
through this simple construct.
That's an extension function
of my callback service.
The first thing I say there
is suspend my coroutines.
So I'm assuming
I'm in a coroutine,
I suspended it right away,
I get my continuation,
and I do my request.
That's it.
I'm suspended.
I'm waiting for a request.
So there it is.
And when the request is done,
I just say resume to coroutine.
That's it.
So this simple lines of code
turns your callback-based API
into a coroutine API
and so makes this--
oh, sorry-- makes
this code into this,
which is a lot more
readable to my sense.
How do you like it?
OK, I see some nods
in the audience.
Thank you.
Yeah, well, actually,
if you wanted
to be a lot more prudent here--
and I'm sure you want to--
you need a catch exceptions.
So catching-- handling your
exceptions is very important.
And that's as easy as this.
Just catch your exception.
Whatever happens on
the-- oh, so sorry.
Not here, of course.
Whatever happens
with your request,
just catch it and
resumeWithException.
So this will propagate
exceptions through coroutines
very nicely.
And you'll be able to write
try catch around here--
like surround this
with try catch--
I'm sorry, whatever-- and
catch exceptions there,
as if it was sequential code.
But underneath, it's
all asynchronous.
You can do HTTP requests like
this, asyncio, file systems.
You can do background
threads-- everything you need.
See how isn't it nice?
And I guess, the last example
I'll be showing you today
is this one.
It's just another showoff for
how coroutines can help you.
Take a look.
So what I want to
do is to create
an infinite stream of numbers.
Who likes infinite
streams of numbers?
I eat them for breakfast.
So I want just a Fibonacci
sequence to be generated here.
And then, I can take 20 of them.
Here, just a sequence of 20.
I can take 200, 2,000.
I can filter, map,
slice, whatever.
So this buildSequence
function is a library function
in the Kotlin standard library.
And it's actually based on the
same mechanism as coroutines.
It doesn't do any
background processing.
It's all in the same thread.
What it does, it takes all the
yield statements from here,
and just puts them
in a sequence.
So if I want to yield something
here, I'll just do it.
I insert 2 into my sequence.
If I want to--
say, if tmp is greater
than 10, continue--
I can skip pieces of my logic.
So that's as straightforward
as any coroutine.
It gives you a lazy sequence.
So takeaways--
classes are cheap.
Functions are
top-level or local.
No overloading to emulate
your default values.
Use properties, use delegated
properties, use coroutines.
Have a nice Kotlin.
And I want to advertise
some more activities today.
So if you still have questions
that I couldn't take,
you can come over to an office
hour we're having at 12:30.
You can come over
to the sandbox area
C, where we're at the
Kotlin booth, some
of the day at least.
And right after my
talk, there will
be a talk by Jake Wharton
about Android KDX, which
is very exciting.
I believe it's on stage two,
so you're welcome there.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]